ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States let me
just say when you look at the tragic
events in Houston and you look into the
faces of these people who have lost
everything I think we can all agree this
has been my best week yet I mean look at
me I get to talk on a truck sir we can
see that's not a real truck yeah that's
right dummy it's a fire truck and I got
my raincoat my hat isn't it cool I look
like I'm helping
how can you congratulate yourself at a
time like this
I'm not congratulating myself we're not
gonna do that until this is all over and
cleaned up in two three days max I want
to ask you about North Korea you tweeted
that talking is not the answer so what
is I don't know the answer but I do know
the question and that question is what
is the answer are you kidding exactly
next question okay do you support your
party's idea to cut 1 billion dollars
from disaster funds to pay for your
border wall of course the wall would
have prevented this entire thing I mean
where did Harvey come from the Gulf of
where where Mexico you said it not me
it's an illegal storm they're sending
their worst winds their hardest rains
there's some bad storm breads you can't
be mean to me I'm wearing my raincoat
I'm a storm time president I'm steering
the ship I'm leading the truck and
that's why tonight's theme is leader
truck by man leadership toot-toot
honk-honk I'm the president can you
release it what's wrong